I'll tear told his Lord King Alfred that
he dwelt the farthest north of all the
Norwegians he said that he lived in the
northern part of the country bordering
the North Sea yet he told Alfred that
that land extends very far to the north
from that place but it is all desert
except but in a few places here and
there the laps live by hunting in winter
and by fishing along the shore in the
summer he said that on one occasion he
decided to find out how far the country
extended due north and whether anyone
dwelt to the north of that desolate land
[Music]
then he went due north along the coast
for the whole journey he kept the
wasteland on his starboard and the open
sea on his port for three days then he
was as far north as the whale hunters
travel at their farthest then he still
went on as far jus north as he might
sail in another three days then the land
or the estuary within the land he could
not determine which turned their juist
but he knew that he waited there for a
westerly and slightly northern wind and
then he sailed east along the coast as
far as he might sail in four days then
he had to wait there for a northerly
wind because the land or the estuary
within the land he could not determine
which turned there due south then he
sailed due south from there along the
coast as far as he might sail in five
days
[Music]
then a great river extends far inland
they turned inland up this river because
they dared not sail beyond the river for
fear of attack since the land on the
other bank of the river was well
inhabited otter had not previously found
any inhabited country after he had left
his own home but throughout the journey
the land on his starboard side was
deserted
apart from fissures and Fowler's and
hunters they were all laps and on his
port lay always to the open sea the
permeance had very greatly cultivated
their land but they dared not venture
there in but the land of the tur Finn's
was all deserted except where hunters or
Fowler's or fishers dwelt the permeance
gave him much information both of their
own land and the lands that lay about
them but he might not know how true it
was because he had not seen it for
himself
the laps and the permian speak as it
seemed to him virtually one language
most of all hot air went thither in
addition to exploring the land for
walruses because they have very fine
bones in their tusks they brought some
tusks to King Alfred and their hides are
good for ship's cables this sea beast is
much smaller than other sea beasts it is
no longer than seven ELLs long but in
his own country is the best wailing they
are 48 ELLs long and the greatest are 50
ELLs long he said that with five
companions he killed 60 in two days
hot air was a very wealthy man in those
possessions in which their wealth
consists that is in wild animals yet he
had when he came to visit King Alfred
six hundred beasts unsold they call
these beasts reindeer six of them were
trained as decoys they were highly
prized among the laps because with them
they capture wild reindeer otter was
among the foremost men of that land yet
he did not have more than twenty head of
cattle and twenty sheep and twenty pigs
and the little that he ploughed he
plowed by horses but their revenue is
greatest in the tribute to which the
laps paid to them that's tribute
consists of the skins of animals and the
feathers of birds and the bones of
whales and it ships cables which are
made from the skins of whales and seals
a man of the highest rank has to
contribute the skins of 15 Martens and
five reindeer and one bear and 40
bushels of feathers and a tunic made of
bearskin or otter skin and two ships
cables both must be 60 ELLs long they
must be made either of whale skin or of
seal skin
altaïr said that the land of the
Norwegians was very long and very narrow
all the to man might graze or plow lay
along the coast and even so it was in
some places very rocky and wild moors
lie to the east off and above the
cultivated land and those moors dwelve
elapsed and the cultivated land is
widest in an eastward direction and
always the more northerly it is the more
narrow it becomes eastwards it may be
sixty miles wide or a little wider and
in the middle thirty miles wide or a
little wider and in the north where it
is most narrow he says that it might be
three miles wide up to the moor and
thereafter the moor is in some places so
wide that a man may cross it in two
weeks and in other places so wide that a
man may cross it in six days then
alongside that land toward the south on
the other side of the mall is Sweden
until it meets that land in the north
and alongside that land towards the
north is the land of the Finns sometimes
the Finns Harry the Norwegians across
them or sometimes the Norwegians Harry
the Finns
and there are very great freshwater
lakes throughout the Moors and the Finns
carry their boats overland onto these
lakes and thence attack the Norwegians
they have very small and portable boats
hot air said that the region in which he
lived is called hallo girl and he said
that no one lived to the north of him
then there is one port to the south of
the region which is called scaring
Michelle he says that a man might sail
thither in a month if he camped at night
and had each day a favourable wind and
all this time he should sail along the
coast and on his starboard he passed his
first Iceland and then the islands that
lie between Iceland and this land and
then this land lasts until he comes to
scre English yell and throughout the
journey Norway lies on his port side to
the south of scurrying ashell the great
Baltic Sea flows inland it is broader
than anyone may see across and Jutland
lies opposite on the other side and then
Zealand this sea extends many hundreds
of miles into the surrounding lands and
he says that in five days he sailed from
scoring a shell to the port called head
a big it is sighted between the lands of
the when's and the Saxons and the angles
and it pays tribute to Denmark when he
sailed vivir from scaring to shell
Denmark was on his port and the open sea
on his starboard for three days and then
for the two days before he came to the
port of Hedda be on his starboard lay
Jutland and Zealand and many islands in
these lands the English lived before
they came hither across the sea and for
those two days the island which pays
tribute to Denmark was on his port side
[Music]
you